le sujet est pris très au sérieux par le
département d'état et même par la maison
blanche avant même que les troupes de
vladimir poutine ne franchisse la
frontière ukrainienne le 24 février
dernier pour mener disons le une
offensive qui a tout simplement sidéré
le monde les services de renseignement
américains travaillait sur l'hypothèse
déjà d'une utilisation d'armes chimiques
par les troupes russes alors stacho
stationnées à la frontière une hypothèse
qui n'a strictement jamais quitté les
préoccupations de l'administration
américaine et qui n'a pas cessé non plus
d'être partagé par le gouvernement
ukrainien et l'ensemble des observateurs
occidentaux concernés par la guerre en
ukraine et puis depuis 24 heures les
témoignages remonte de marioupol cette
fois des témoignages soigneusement
recueillis éplucher et vérifiés par le
département d'état et disons le car
c'est un secret de polichinelle par les
agents du renseignement américains
présents sur le territoire ukrainien
l'armée russe a t'elle utiliser
l'arsenal chimiques à marioupol les
témoignages de soldats ukrainien qui se
plaignent de troubles respiratoires
peuvent qu'y d'être confirmé pas pour le
moment répond anthony blinken lui même
ce mardi mais alors que joe biden dans
un discours en iowa le même jour à
utiliser le mot de génocide en ukraine
pour dénoncer l'intervention russe il
est permis de considérer que l'hypothèse
de la violation du tabou des armes
chimiques sur le champ de bataille
ukrainien serait la transgression de
trop pour l'amérique